[scream fades
into a groan]
OW.
[groans]
OW! THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, ALEXEI.
THIS LOOKS FINE, RIGHT?
- YEAH, IT'S FINE.
WE'RE READY TO GO.
- YEAH, PEOPLE BLEED AT PARTIES.
- YEAH, TOTALLY.
- I GET THAT.
- YOU READY?
- YEAH.
- OKAY, HERE WE GO.
READY, AND...ACTION.
[funky hip-hop music]
- YO, WHAT'S UP?
IT'S ADAM DEVINE.
WELCOME TO MY HOUSE PARTY.
COMEDY CENTRAL GAVE ME
A BUNCH OF MONEY
TO THROW
AN AWESOME COMEDY SHOW,
AND--AND I BLEW IT ALL
ON THIS HOUSE PARTY--
CUT. KYLE.
I DON'T FEEL LIKE
WE'RE CAPTURING
THE ESSENCE OF THE SHOW
RIGHT NOW.
- YOU DON'T CALL CUT.
YOU'RE NOT THE DIRECTOR, MAN.
- OKAY, NO, I'M SORRY,
AND I RESPECT YOU
AS A DIRECTOR,
BUT QUITE FRANKLY,
I THINK YOU'RE LOSING CONTROL
A LITTLE BIT,
AND I HAVE A BETTER IDEA
THAN WHAT--
WHAT YOU'RE GIVING ME
RIGHT NOW.
SO LET'S CUT AND START AGAIN,
STARTING NOW.
CUT AND ACTION.
GO.
- ALL RIGHT,
LET'S ROLL SOUND.
- AND ALSO ROLL SOUND.
[funky hip-hop music]
- YO, WHAT'S UP?
IT'S ADAM DEVINE.
AND THIS IS MY HOUSE PARTY.
COMEDY CENTRAL GAVE ME
A BUNCH OF MONEY
TO THROW
A STAND-UP COMEDY SHOW,
BUT I BLEW IT ALL
ON THIS GIANT HOUSE
TO THROW A PARTY IN.
LET'S JUST SAY
WE HAVE A LITTLE SOMETHING
FOR EVERYBODY.
ZOINKS!
WHAT THE [bleep]?
- HEY, WHAT'S UP, ADAM?
DUDE, WHAT HAPPENED
TO YOUR HEAD?
- DOESN'T MATTER, DUDE.
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE?
BRINGING MY EX-GIRLFRIEND
TO THE PARTY
THAT I'M INVITING YOU TO,
WHERE I'M GONNA PUT YOU UP
AS A BIG-TIME STAND-UP COMEDIAN?
- OH, I DIDN'T KNOW
YOU GUYS HAD DATED.
- WE WENT ON ONE DATE.
- WE WENT OUT ON ONE DATE.
SEE HOW WE ALMOST FINISHED
EACH OTHER'S SENTENCE THERE?
- MM-HMM.
- WE SHOULD'VE GROWN OLD
TOGETHER AND DIED,
BUT SOMEONE THOUGHT SOMEONE
WAS STRANGE, YOU KNOW.
- OKAY, WELL, DUDE,
YOU'RE DOING AWESOME.
- MM, IT MAY LOOK LIKE THAT,
BUT THIS IS ALL A FACADE,
BECAUSE I'M BROKEN INSIDE
BECAUSE I STILL LOVE SOMEONE.
- OKAY, HE DOES THIS.
LET'S GET ANOTHER DRINK.
- LATER, SANTINO.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, BRO.
ALL RIGHT.
HEY, BRO, I'M NOT EVEN MAD.
I'M NOT EVEN MAD!
- [chuckles]